don't ruin barb Rafi
guys did you get to watch while you're
getting ready yeah what did you think of
the show
incredible Eminem Elton John Tyco
Congrats bar legend did you see his
moment on instagram after someone caught
him tucking the Oscar under the chair in
front of him like down with his snacks
really I didn't say that it's incredible
Brad Pitt winning yeah that was amazing
it was nicest room in in Hollywood as
long as Brad Pitt I think his speech
must have meant something to you is very
inspirational I thought I thought his
speech was awesome we write love about
having a drink we saw it was good
he's a legend did you think of the cat's
moment with rebel and James Corden how
many times have you seen cats I've seen
cats no times because you love it I've
seen it you know it's twice about Cass
do you love it
I plan on seeing at a third time you do
yeah I'm drunk every single time that's
why I'm saying I had to see a lot of
movies this year in casting you see cats
I'm not a fan a digital fur technology
digital fur technologies what they call
me why do you have a stance against it
I'm not for it I'm gonna say it right
here what's your favorite cat's
character please no Judi Dench cat oh
you don't like Judi dancer I loved what
are you guys wearing tonight tell me
about this cover band matching we
decided to go with the silat yeah I got
we are gonna go catch up to the rest of
the family silk shirts in 2020 okay
thank you
[Music]